Home Secretary are you a threat to
National Security
forced out of her job after sharing a
sensitive document from her personal
email swella bravman says she reported
the breach rapidly some question this
and say others flagged it reappointed
home secretary by Rishi sunak cabinet
ministers defended their colleague Sue
Ella is a first-rate front rank
politician she acknowledged that a
mistake had been made she is working
hard in order to ensure that our borders
can be made more secure and that
policing is more effective and she's a
valued member of the cabinet and someone
whom I admire and like Sue Ella bravaman
initially shared the document at 7 25 am
on the 19th of October an hour later one
of the recipients replied saying they'd
been sent it in error 90 minutes later
the home secretaries account sent a
message asking for the email to be
deleted then at midday four and a half
hours after the breach and two hours
after the follow-up email Mrs bravaman
instructed officials to report the
incident you can't have a Home Secretary
who is not trusted by the security
service who is not trusted with
important government information and it
really shows the huge error of judgment
that Rishi sunak has made in
reappointing someone just six days after
she broke the ministerial code
there's also been criticism about a
dangerously overcrowded Asylum Center in
Kent the home office forced to deny
reports that legal advice about moving
people from the site was ignored this
all matters because it throws doubt onto
Sue Ella bravaman's competency and
honesty and also calls into question the
Judgment of the Prime Minister one
former cabinet minister accused Rishi
sunak of striking a grubby deal to get
her support and questioned how this fit
with his commitment to transparency and
integrity officials here at the home
office are said to be livid and this
isn't the only security concern around
at the moment
the mail on Sunday reported that Liz
truss had her phone hacked while foreign
secretary with up to a Year's worth of
messages downloaded the government
hasn't confirmed this but Former
Intelligence analysts say Security
Services need to have confidence in the
cabinet ministers they deal with if
trust does break down then then that's a
problem and That Could That Could lead
to if not withholding of information
then some heightened briefing and
conversations and discussions about the
um the importance of making sure that
the the proper protocols and procedures
and behaviors are followed
since taking office Rishi sunak has
brought a degree of calm to Westminster
but with big challenges ahead the
backlash to his choice of Home Secretary
shows there's still ample space for
anger and disagreement
Rob Powell Sky News in Westminster